move over sound of music take a hike
mother teresa cause there's a new
christian
in town
yes hbo europe's 30 coins gives us the
most frightening thing to come out of
spain since
antonio banderas played the phantom
[Music]
so come and join me in this sunday
school lesson as i explain
what exactly happened in that ending who
father vergara and father
angelo really are and what might be in
store for season two
but before we begin make sure to like
and subscribe or you'll burn in hell
the last episode is called sacrificio
and if my high school spanish is any
good that means
sacrifice and just like jesus sacrificed
himself for
our sins so too does father manuel
vergara but we'll get into that in a bit
the small spanish town of pedraza is
under the control of father angelo who
has spent the last few years collecting
the 30 coins to usher in a new era of
sin the 30 coins are the roman coins
given to judas for betraying jesus an
event which is depicted in the
introductory titles it is said whoever
holds all 30 will wield a weapon of
unimaginable power which would usher in
a new
world order
napoleon once held three of these coins
and hitler five
so imagine what all 30 could do in
episode 3 we learn of the order of the
canigs the group that wants to collect
all these artifacts they're led by a
catholic priest father fabio santoro a
man who lusts for power and knowledge of
the unknown
his order even has a whole room devoted
to the gospels that
didn't make it into the bible and other
forbidden texts
among these are the three gifts the magi
gave to jesus on his birth but they're
not gold frankincense and myrrh like the
bible would tell you
their magic spells the miracles jesus
performed
weren't miracles they were spells
but who really are these members of the
order of the canines and why would they
want to commit evil
according to father vergara the order
believes that by doing evil they are
following god's divine plan
the logic goes something like this if
god is all-powerful then he should be
able to stop
sickness war poverty basically all that
evil stuff
but he doesn't therefore evil must be a
part of god's divine plan
so by doing evil you're basically
playing a necessary role in god's plan
the order also follows an alternative
view of jesus's death put forward in the
gospel of judas a real document said to
have been written somewhere in the 3rd
century a.d and discovered in the 1970s
it's important to note that you can't
find this gospel in the bible but if
you're interested you can
find it online it details that judas
wasn't a betrayer but that jesus knew he
was to die and asked judas to betray him
so that he could be sacrificed
we also have this guy named angelo or
angel the entity who ends up
orchestrating the collection of the
coins and prepares everything for
fabio's ascension
as the dark pope he never explicitly
says he's the devil but he definitely
could be his name has angel in it and
satan was an angel who rebelled against
god
in episode 3 we get a flashback of
vergara santoro and sandro in 1990.
santoro has chained angelo in a storage
unit for over two months and this angelo
guy
claims god is a madman who enjoys
watching humans suffer
after the great battle between satan and
god satan withdrew his men to a safe
place hiding in an aspect of god
called hell this battle erupted because
the angels who were tasked with
committing evil by god
were never given credit for their part
in god's divine plan
they're kind of like the judases of the
afterlife constantly being blamed for
bad things even though they're just
doing what they've been told
god of course couldn't allow the
rebellious angels into the control of
satan to get credit because
that would mean exposing their evil as
part of himself
what i'm getting at here is that god is
basically good
and evil it's a delicate balancing act
but with the 30 coins the koenigs want
to tip the balance of power in their
favor the last episode begins with
father angelo awaiting the arrival of
fabio santoro they soon
to be dark pope i guess they need a
human to fill this role kind of like how
jesus filled that role for god
he's created a fog around the town using
a spell involving the blood of unborn
children which forbids anyone from
leaving
he's also mind controlled almost all the
town's people via unholy communion
anyone who takes communion falls under
his control we see this when mercy isn't
under his control opting to save her
communion wafers vergara arrives back in
town to face his demons
literally in a very weird battle with a
giant hell demon that drops burned
hellspawn he shoots a version of himself
after which the creature disappears but
why would vergara's soul
be in hell as we'll find out later
vergara has been working this entire
time for satan in the season's climax
angelo reveals that vergara was
chosen by him he needed someone who
could resist temptation all these years
without crumbling under the pressure
someone who could hold on to the coin
for safe keeping
and not give into its power until he was
needed it's never revealed in the show
why angelo couldn't hold on to the coin
himself it's only hinted that the coin
will always find a way out of hell
because it doesn't want to be there
that's why he needed someone on earth to
hold it for him this is also why he has
minions like father lagrange or
manipulate others to steal the coins
in episode five it's hinted that vergara
is like the judas of the canites
this man has betrayed his loved ones
too for the sake of our cause
father centauro says vergara sacrificed
everything his family his friends his
job
even spent years in prison for the sake
of protecting the coin
this man has protected for years the
holy coin of betrayal with his life
but vergara has no idea what's going on
he believes he's protecting the coin
from the order not holding it for them
after all angelo didn't give him the
coin he got it during a botched exorcism
years ago one which saw a young boy
named giacomo
die of a heart attack and vergara being
sent to jail what he didn't know was
that giacomo was angelo and
angelo is giacomo the devil can take
many forms as is evidenced in one of the
final scenes where we see his reflection
change
the dark pope ends up stabbing vergara
with a spear of longinus the spear that
stabbed christ as he hung from the cross
and there is a lot of symbolism
throughout the series of vergara being
christ-like if you can get past the fact
he kills a lot of people like him being
referred to as the chosen one
bloody palms like jesus's hands being
nailed on the cross
or even godlike powers that allow him to
snap a knife with his bare hands
i don't remember jesus doing that in the
bible but if he did i sure as hell would
have paid more attention
with all 30 coins set within the dark
pope's hat fabio centauro addresses the
crowd of gathered canites signaling the
beginning of the end
but vergara has one more trick up his
sleeve earlier in the episode he used
the blood of saint ambrose to conjure a
spell and take control of a dove he uses
this dove to distract fabio allowing him
to sacrifice himself by throwing him off
the edge of the church the dark pope's
hat falls off scattering the coins
everywhere causing the canines to
viciously fight for their control
now this is absolutely setting us up for
a season 2 essentially resetting the
coins to be found
all over again and that's exactly what
happens with mercy who conveniently
finds one underneath her shoe with her
being rejected by
paco it looks like she'll be teaming up
with father lagrange who seemed to be
flirting with her earlier in the episode
to possibly collect the coins all over
again
now we have to ask ourselves is father
vergara dead
i wouldn't count on it with all the
christ symbolism
resurrection spells angels and whatnot
in this show i wouldn't count them out
the guy also fell from a height shorter
than antonio did in episode one and
antonio survived so who knows then
there's elena who was stabbed with a
cursed pin
normally something this size wouldn't
kill you but since it was cursed by the
cockroach lady it seems to be far more
dangerous
the question that remains is if the
curse will have any lingering effects
like will it make it so paco and elena
can't fall in love because
as the old lady said to mercy now he's
all yours
finally i want to talk about angelo
morphing into this asian man i checked
the credits and he's simply referred to
as
asiatico or asian judging by this and
the actors
slim imdb credits over the years i don't
think this is some big new character for
season 2
really the purpose of this last scene is
to show us two things
that angelo can morph into different
forms and that he has business in new
york
but check this out if you pause here you
can tell it's not
an asian man did they not have money to
fly the actor out to new york or has
angelo shape-shifted once again
other than that there's not much to go
on but if i were to guess what the main
plot of season 2 will be
it's three groups vying to collect the
30 coins
we have paco elena and vergara as group
1 lagrange and mercy as group 2
and angelo as group 3. so i'm excited to
see how this plays out but what did you
think of 30
coins and do you have any theories on
season 2 let me know in the comments
below
thanks for watching everyone please make
sure to like subscribe and share and for
more bad takes you can follow me on
twitter and instagram at thinkstoryyt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much